este es el último día de la cumbre
amazónica de periodismo y cambio
climático que france24 ha cubierto del 8
al 11 de junio aquí se reunieron
periodistas de países como eeuu méxico
perú colombia y por supuesto ecuador
ellos están discutiendo cómo contar la
crisis climática sin embargo los grandes
protagonistas han sido los indígenas
quienes no solo vinieron a aprender sino
también a demostrar cómo con la
comunicación han combatido también la
crisis climática y es que de los 14
pueblos indígenas que hay en ecuador 11
de estas naciones se ubican en la región
amazónica y además el 8 por ciento de la
población ecuatoriana se considera
indígena según el plan nacional de
desarrollo algunos de los indígenas que
han sido pioneros en la comunicación han
sido los quechua de sarayaku quienes
lograron que en 2012 la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos
fallara una histórica sentencia a su
favor sobre la consulta previa que ha
sido pionera en toda la región la
consulta previa es el mecanismo en el
que los estados consultarle a las
comunidades étnicas si aprueban o no
proyectos extractivistas en sus
territorios y ellos nos han mostrado
cómo con la comunicación la política y
la justicia han combatido la crisis
climática hasta aquí nuestro cubrimiento
de la cumbre y sigan ustedes en france24
con más información ambiental